Well,
first of all,
I mean,
mostly what I do is analysis and if we
think about analysis,
whether it's a book or an opinion
column,
when it works,
it helps you read the newspaper better,
right?
I mean,
it's,
it,
it's not just giving people information,
it's giving people analysis and
connecting the dots between a few
different pieces of information that
creates that sort of Aha click of
clarity.
Um,
and when you read strong analysis,
clear analysis and it makes you feel
better equipped,
right?
It's sort of ammo and um,
so as an opinion writer,
as a columnist,
I know that that's my goal is helping
people get more of those cliques of
understanding because I think that we
feel bombarded with information.
We are bombarded with information,
but we are extremely disoriented and
the,
what I'm doing now,
what I'm trying to do now with this book
is I feel like we're still in somewhat
of a state of shock from September 11th.
Uh,
and that a state of shock is about a gap
that opens up between an event and,
and,
and our analysis of that event.
And that's what shocked means something
happens that so big that we lose our
collective story.
And I think the Bush administration has
been really adept at heightening that
state of disorientation by telling
people everything you thought you knew
before September 11th is wrong.
We're rebooting history,
we're starting over.
Right?
And if you think about what,
what,
what most people wanted to do after
September 11th is they actually wanted
to do the work to integrate that event
into their story,
right?
This,
this was an event that seemed to come
out of nowhere,
but nothing comes out of nowhere.
So people wanted to know history and
the,
they were hungry for that knowledge that
could bridge the gap between event and
collective and enter collective story.
Um,
so I guess that's what I see myself
doing is helping that bridging process
because when we're in a state of shock,
we're very vulnerable to political
manipulation.
We're frightened,
we regress.
We think Rudy Giuliani's are long lost
daddy,
you know,
I mean,
this is dangerous.
And I think,
you know,
good politicians were effective
politicians,
not good politicians,
but effective politicians understand
that they are very powerful in those
moments when people are disoriented.
So analysis a,
it connects the dots,
gives us a new story and orients us.
Uh,
and that's when we're better citizens.
That's when we can engage in debates.
That's when were harder to manipulate.
That's when we're smarter,
a calmer,
more focused.
Um,
so,
you know,
that's what,
that's what all analysis.